in Virginia two people working for
Democratic Congressman Jerry Connolly
were attacked Yesterday by a man with a
baseball bat now a short time earlier a
home security camera captured video of
the suspect look at him chasing a
different woman in another location you
can hear her screaming there Nicole
Killian has more on this story
a chaotic scene inside of Congressman
Jerry Connolly Suburban Virginia office
after police say a 49 year old man went
on a rampage Monday attacking two
staffers including an intern with a
metal baseball bat we had a young intern
her first day on the job at the
reception desk and she told us I wasn't
there he then proceeded to beat her with
the bat the suspect Juan Kar trammed fam
is charged with two counts including
aggravated malicious wounding
police are also investigating an earlier
alleged incident where he's seen chasing
a woman with a bat before going to
Connolly's office the suspect's father
told the Washington Post that his son
has suffered from schizophrenia since he
was a teen it's quite frankly scary that
someone can just walk up to an office
holding a baseball bat and just start
swinging the incident comes after a
string of recent violent attacks
involving lawmakers it's our staff and
our family who sit on the target we're
often in transit and and so you know
this is just an escalation you know we
could have disagreements you know
politics obviously it's competitive but
people shouldn't be attacked the
Virginia Democrat says he doesn't
believe this attack was politically
motivated but he plans to reevaluate his
security I'm certainly cognizant of the
fact I was the target
I also feel
I don't know the word is guilty that
instead of me getting hurt my staff did
U.S Capitol Police Chief Tom manger says
threats against lawmakers have increased
about 400 percent over the last six
years he testifies today on the hill and
has asked Congress for more funding to
increase hiring and security Nate
Nicole thank you